you launched video on Instagram in June
2013 95 million photos and videos now
shared daily on the service what's the
breakdown between photos and video well
you know it's crazy about video is that
everyone who wrote it off I mean there
were a lot of photo services back in the
day online that would add video because
it just made sense it was a visual
medium but it never really took off what
we've seen over the last six months is
that basically the video has a video
watch time people spending time watching
video has increased a hundred and fifty
percent and just a you know those short
months so what's crazy for us is that we
have this moment in time where
instagrams becoming more and more video
dominant video heavy and I think that's
just a sign of the times people are
taking more video consuming more video
and frankly all these influencers that
exist on Instagram that we just talked
about that will be going to VidCon
they're all video heavy as well I think
it's a generational thing as well and
you're moving into longer form video up
to 60 seconds right yes what is the
vision here this would be around big
events presumably like the Oscars or the
Superbowl or at work you know whenever
the the idea of expanding to 60 seconds
is as we talk to our consumers remember
I said that it's all about being
community first the feedback we received
is 15 seconds is just too short to share
anything compelling and dynamic so as we
talk to these influencers celebrities
etc they have they have these messages
that they want to share whether it's
clips from their shows they do you know
video podcasts basically they want to
share their content on Instagram and we
want to make sure that they're able to
do it in more than 15 seconds Facebook
and Twitter keep talking about live live
events live video event based products
you have dipped a toe into this your
journeys compilations after big events
what is your strategy around live in
particular and how do you get more of it
well I believe that our opportunity is
Instagram is to capture and share the
world's moments both in the moment and
after the moment so if you want to go on
to Instagram and you want to be able to
know what's happening in the world we
need to be able to show it to you and
that's what we use our explore page for
so when you go on to explore you can tap
in after EDC EDC's this big electronic
dance music festival happening in Las
Vegas right now we have this awesome
compilation about that we have awesome
compilations after the fact to like we
compilations of chefs making dishes it's
all about knowing what's happening in
the world right now and being able to
come to Instagram as a media destination
as the place to know what's happening
the visual pulse of the world will we
see live streaming on Instagram you may
someday I mean obviously Facebook's tip
to toe into it is going oh it's more
than just telling do it they're growing
heavy into it and we have that
technology to leverage as well what's
important to us is to figure out how it
fits into Instagram because you don't
just want to like adopt a technology and
say great now we have live you have to
figure out exactly how it works inside
of Instagram and how it'll be different
than all the other offerings what do you
feel as competition where do I start the
crazy thing about you know serving a
service that starts at like 21 minutes a
day on average for every single user is
that time is of the essence I mean we as
consumers only have limited amount of
time to pull out our phones and do
something so anyone who's competing for
time but the Facebook family continues
to grow and share on time and continues
to you know be the destination that
people love spending time and mobile and
anyone who competes against that I guess
as a competitor but at the end of the
day we're focused inwards and we deliver
on creative product can we deliver on
creative content is that experience
compelling and does that like help
people spend time on Instagram that's
what we're focused on
when you say Instagram you want to
Instagram to reflect what's happening in
your world it sounds a lot like what
Twitter says what Jack Dorsey says about
Twitter do you see yourself competing
more head-to-head with Twitter obviously
they don't have the user numbers you do
well I think the reason why I'm smiling
is because what social media outlet
doesn't say this right because that's
the great that's the great opportunity
of our time the thing that didn't exist
10 years ago that could exist 10 years
from now is knowing in any corner of the
planet what's happening right now and I
believe visual imagery is a great way to
go about doing that now on snapchat in
particular one employee told us that
they're concerned that Facebook and
Instagram aren't more scared of snapchat
are you afraid enough a snapchat I don't
think it's our job to be afraid so much
as understand what's happening in the
world
I think we are competing against many
different services for
time and eyeballs etc but getting to 500
million users around the world is a big
feat I mean 300 million of those are
daily actives that's 300 million people
that open up Instagram every single day
21 minutes a day that's a big feat we
are absolutely not
sitting you know happy thinking that
that's gonna last forever we need to
keep innovating and keep introducing
products but that's why over the last
five and a half years we've shown that
our track record is to do that and to
continue growing so there will always be
other companies but there's also
Instagram and we're gonna continue
pushing on it is there anything about
snapchat that you admire or have you
shared any lessons yeah no snapshots an
amazing company and I really respect
everything that they're doing I mean
they've taken you know the thing that we
love as well and really catapulted it
which is visual sharing and I love that
more people are taking photos today than
they were you know two years ago because
of companies like snapchat and others
periscope is a great example of this
we're all pushing on the same direction
and what's cool is we're actually seeing
the vision come to fruition which is
everyone's communicating visually now
and Instagram is a big part of that
ecosystem so what happens to all of
these companies that are trying to do
the same thing do are some left standing
and some not well there are different
flavors I mean there are a lot of people
that thought well Instagram and Facebook
can't really exist in the same world and
Twitter right but it turns out all these
companies have hundreds of millions of
users and are growing fairly nicely I
mean it depends which company we're
talking about but at the same time
Instagram continues to do that and when
we talk to people they talk about how
Instagram fits a very unique space in
their life what they love about it is
they can connect with interest accounts
whether it's you know a chef an amazing
you know animator trick videos those
types of things you can only find those
on Instagram and that's the unique value
that they see on that note is Facebook
competition is whatsapp competition
people in your own family well we don't
like to see it as that I actually I have
great relationships with Mark and Yann
and Brendan from oculus we actually try
to spend our time figuring out how to
work together more than how to work
against each other
we obviously overlap in some use cases
but I think the surprising thing about
combining these companies is how
wonderfully like they work
together actually to achieve a greater
mission sharing content between sharing
networks between and making it easier
for the consumer to access what they
want which is compelling content